This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执业专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，听听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
用艰难的方式在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《情感陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情感陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are going to talk about one of the most valuable skills that we can learn and that we can perfect during this decade, and that is mastering public speaking, mastering how to hold a crowd, how to get your point across and be convincing in our professional lives, in business when speaking about the things that we're passionate about, essentially knowing
相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝，在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，和我们一起剖析二十多岁时的心理学。今天，我们要聊的是我们在这一十年里可以学到并完善的最宝贵的技能之一，那就是掌握公开演讲，掌握如何掌控全场，如何把你的观点表达清楚并在我们的职业生活中、在商业中谈论我们热爱的事物时具有说服力，本质上就是知道
how to walk onto a stage or into a room and just nail it and just leave people thinking, this person knows what they're talking about. It is a rare skill, but a really, really important one, you know, from having to defend a thesis or pitch to investors or to a new employer or talk at your best friend's wedding. Public speaking is such a great opportunity to really impress or entertain a lot of people and hopefully be remembered. But it's something that is, quite terrifying. I think the scary part of public speaking is the possibility of not only being remembered, but of being remembered in a way that is not favourable, of being judged or noticed. That is where our fear of public speaking really comes from. You know, as social creatures, it's a bit of
如何走上舞台或走进房间，然后一鸣惊人，让人们觉得，这个人真的懂他在说什么。这是一项罕见的技能，但却是一项非常非常重要的技能，你知道的，无论是为毕业论文辩护、向投资者或新雇主进行推介，还是在最好朋友的婚礼上发言。公开演讲是一个绝佳的机会，可以真正给很多人留下深刻印象或带来娱乐，并希望被人记住。但这确实是一件让人感到相当恐惧的事情。我认为公开演讲最可怕的部分，不仅在于可能被记住，而且在于以一种不被看好的方式被记住，被评判或被注意到。这才是我们对公开演讲的恐惧真正来源的地方。你知道的，作为社会生物，这其实是一种
a natural fear because humans are very paralysed by the notion of doing wrong or making a mistake, especially in front of a large group of people whose opinions we care about most. In fact, our biggest collective fear as a species, it's not death, it's not spiders, it's not clowns, it is actually public speaking. 75% of us have this fear according to the National Institute of Mental Health. It's otherwise known as glossophobia, such a pretty name for something that can be very paralyzing. And I think it really comes down to not just confidence, but trust. Trusting ourselves and knowing that whatever happens, we are going to be okay. We trust ourselves to do well, to perform
很自然的恐惧，因为人类非常害怕做错事或犯错误的观念，特别是当着一群我们最在意其意见的大多数人的面时。事实上，作为人类这个物种，我们最大的集体恐惧不是死亡，不是蜘蛛，不是小丑，实际上是公开演讲。根据美国国家心理健康研究所的数据，我们当中有75%的人都有这种恐惧。它也被称为恐言症（glossophobia），对于一个可能让人非常瘫痪的症状来说，这名字还蛮好听的。而我认为这归根结底不仅是自信，还有信任。信任我们自己，知道无论发生什么，我们都会没事的。我们相信自己能做好，能表现得
well. And sometimes that trust is nowhere to be found. I used to be so terrified of public speaking back in the day. I remember pretending to be sick when we'd have to do speeches or like debating at school, any kind of performing. I just couldn't do it. And I actually went to a school that was really focused on music and performing arts. So you can see how that was going to be a bit of a problem. I remember having to do like a singing performance, not quite public speaking, but a performance nonetheless. And I held the microphone so far away from me that no one was even able to hear me because I was so scared that people would listen or hear and be like, well, that's, she's just not very good. And although these days I do spend most of my time talking behind a microphone in my studio alone,
出色。而有时这种信任却无处可寻。过去的我对公开演讲感到无比恐惧。我记得在学校里需要做演讲或辩论、任何形式的表演时，我总是假装生病。我就是做不到。事实上我读的那所学校非常注重音乐和表演艺术。所以你可以想象这会是一个多么大的问题。我记得有一次必须进行歌唱表演，虽然算不上严格意义上的公开演讲，但毕竟也是一场表演。我把麦克风拿得离自己远远的，以至于根本没人能听见我的声音，因为我太害怕别人会听见然后觉得，嗯，她就是唱得不太好。虽然现在我把大部分时间都花在了独自在录音室里对着麦克风说话，
I also have to give a lot of talks and speak to huge rooms of strangers to perform keynotes, presentations, inspirational speeches, whatever you can imagine. Nowadays, I get a real energy from it. And I find that it is a great part of what I do. I'm excited by it. I love reaching people. I love talking to them, convincing them, maybe inspiring them, I can hope. And with that practice, with that exposure to public speaking that I've had,
但我也必须进行大量的演讲，向挤满陌生人的大房间发言，做主题演讲、演示、励志演讲，你能想象到的各种形式。如今，我能从中获得真正的能量。我发现这是我所做工作的一个绝妙部分。它让我感到兴奋。我喜欢接触人们，喜欢与他们对话，说服他们，或许还能激励他们，我希望如此。通过这些练习，通过我所经历的公开演讲的锻炼，
I've developed a number of skills that have taken me from someone who was very, very anxious in doing so and really did avoid it to someone who can, you know, kind of see it as a walk in a park and who feels very confident now in my ability. So I want to speak about it today. I want to speak to our natural fear of public speaking and provide you all with my guide for overcoming that fear and for stepping into your confidence, for stepping into your power when you are in the uncomfortable position that a lot of us find ourselves in of having to hold a crowd, hold an audience, persuade an audience, present at work, whatever it may be.
我培养出了一系列技能，让我从一个对此感到非常非常焦虑、甚至真的会逃避的人，变成了一个可以说“这简直小菜一碟”、现在对自己的能力充满自信的人。所以我今天想谈谈这个。我想聊聊我们对公开演讲的自然恐惧，并为大家提供我的指南，帮助你们克服这种恐惧，建立自信，在许多人都会陷入的那种不得不掌控全场、掌控听众、说服听众、在工作中进行展示等无论何种情况的不舒适位置时，展现出你们的力量。
There are so many tips that could help you, that have helped me, that I want to share today, so many small mental mindset shifts and hacks to get you to a place of feeling confident. So without further ado, let us get into the story of how I got great at public speaking and how you can as well. Why exactly are we so afraid of public speaking? You know, we all have to do it at some stage. We all know that people probably won't remember us after a week or after a month. and yet we are united in this very common feeling of anticipation in the moments or even days or weeks before we get on stage, this tingle in our fingers, this nervousness in our bellies, this nausea, this anxiety. And like I explained before, what it really comes down to is A, a fear of judgment
有这么多的技巧可以帮到你，这些技巧曾经帮过我，也是我今天想分享的，有那么多微小的心理心态转变和小窍门，能带你走向自信的感觉。所以废话不多说，让我们进入我如何精通公开演讲以及你如何也能做到的故事吧。为什么我们到底这么害怕公开演讲？你知道的，我们所有人在某个阶段都必须面对它。我们都知道人们可能在一周或一个月后就不会记得我们了。然而，在我们上台前的片刻、甚至几天或几周里，我们却共同拥有这种非常普遍的期待感，手指的微微刺痛，腹部的紧张感，这种恶心感，这种焦虑。就像我之前解释的，这归根结底是A，对评判的恐惧，
and B, our fear of being perceived. From an evolutionary perspective, and I speak about this a lot, so I'm sure you have heard this speech of mine before, but we as humans do have a very innate fear of rejection, because in early societies, being ostracized from the group could threaten survival. It meant less food, less opportunities for shelter, less safety. Speaking in front of an audience triggers this fear, even though it feels like a very different activity to what would usually threaten our survival. it still has the same ability to activate the brains amygdala and initiate a fight or flight response. The same way that we would experience if we were facing a physical threat, public speaking is interpreted as a social threat.
以及B，对被注视的恐惧。从进化的角度来看，我经常谈到这一点，所以我确信你以前听过我的这个演讲，我们人类确实有一种对拒绝的根深蒂固的恐惧，因为在早期社会中，被群体排挤会威胁到生存。这意味着更少的食物，更少的获得庇护所的机会，更少的安全感。在观众面前讲话会触发这种恐惧，尽管这感觉起来与通常会威胁我们生存的活动截然不同，但它仍然具有激活大脑杏仁核并引发战斗或逃跑反应的相同能力。就像我们在面对身体威胁时所经历的一样，公开演讲被解读为一种社会威胁。
Will they think differently of me? Will they think I'm less intelligent, less well spoken, less deserving? And therefore, will they ostracize me? All of that comes down to something that is very, very foundational and fundamental in our DNA as a species. Psychologically, many of us fear these kinds of negative evaluations. We worry about being judged, about being criticized, of embarrassing ourselves. And that's definitely made worse by the fact that in those moments where we are asked to speak publicly, to perform, to present, the stakes often feel a lot higher. we're often in a professional environment or in a situation in which we are being closely observed. We are being watched, judged, thought about.
他们会对我产生不同的看法吗？他们会觉得我智商低、口才差、不配得到这些吗？因此，他们会排挤我吗？所有这一切都归结为作为我们这个物种DNA中非常非常基础和根本的东西。从心理学上讲，我们许多人都害怕这种负面评估。我们担心被评判、被批评、让自己出丑。而当我们被要求公开演讲、进行表演、做展示时，那种孤注一掷的感觉往往让情况变得更糟，因为我们通常身处专业环境或被密切观察的情境中。我们在被观看、被评判、被审视。
Because of that, public speaking heightens self-consciousness and it leads to this phenomena that we know as the spotlight effect. So this is a term used by a social psychologist to explain what it feels like when we know that people are paying attention to us. but ultimately when we also overestimate how negative their opinions will be. We tend to think, you know, just because people can see us, they will automatically think of us poorly or negatively. Our brain likes to catastrophize, likes to put this pessimistic twinge or hue on these experiences. What I always like to remember in these moments when the spotlight effect is really taking hold of me when I feel a lot of eyes on me and they might not be kind eyes, is to think about my own experiences on the other side. My own experiences as an audience member when I watch a live performance or a speech,
正因如此，公开演讲加剧了自我意识，并导致了我们所知的“聚光灯效应”这一现象。这是社会心理学家用来解释当我们知道人们在关注我们时所感受到的那种感觉的术语，但最终，我们也高估了他们的意见会有多负面。我们往往会想，你知道的，仅仅因为人们能看到我们，他们就会自动把我们看得很糟糕或很消极。我们的大脑喜欢把事情灾难化，喜欢给这些经历涂上一层悲观的色彩或基调。每当聚光灯效应真正占据我、当我感到许多目光聚集在我身上而且这些目光可能并不那么友善时，我总是喜欢记住的一点，就是去想想自己在另一端的经历。我作为观众在观看现场表演或演讲时的亲身经历，
a keynote, whatever it is, how much do we actually truly pay attention? Be honest with yourself right now. You know, if someone's on the stage at work, how closely really are you listening? How much do you actually tend to be zoning out? think about the last time you saw someone perform. Could you tell me what they were wearing? Could you tell me the moments when they were nervous? Could you recall where they studded?
主题演讲，无论是什么，我们到底真正投入了多少注意力？现在对自己诚实一点。你知道的，如果有人在工作中的舞台上，你到底有多认真地在听？你其实有多少时间都在走神？想想你上一次看别人表演是什么时候。你能告诉我他们穿的是什么吗？你能指出他们紧张的时刻吗？你能回忆起他们哪里结巴了吗？
You know, could you recall where they forgot a slide when something went wrong? You probably can't. All these details that we obsess over in ourselves, we tend to never see in other people because of the spotlight effect and the fact that we often, think about ourselves much more unkindly and negatively than anybody else is ever thinking about us. And that spotlight effect is often linked to social anxiety and perfectionism. Social anxiety, meaning that we feel a lot more worry and a much more heightened emotional state and anticipatory state
你知道的，你能回忆起他们漏掉了一张幻灯片或者哪里出了问题吗？你大概记不清了。所有这些我们在自己身上执着的细节，我们在别人身上往往从来都看不见，这是因为聚光灯效应，以及这样一个事实：我们经常对自己的评价比任何人对我们的评价都要刻薄和消极。而这种聚光灯效应通常与社交焦虑和完美主义有关。社交焦虑意味着我们感到更多的担忧、更高涨的情绪状态和预期状态，
in relation to what other people are thinking, but also perfectionism in the sense that if it's not perfect if it's not exactly as we want it and how we imagined it, how will we survive by knowing that we've left a poor impression? Essentially all of these psychological mechanisms, what they do is they work to take something that should be quite normal and quite harmless, like speaking in front of other people, and they create and make it into this highly, highly, almost stressful experience, this high stakes experience, this experience that feels intrinsically linked to all these other parts of us and all these other parts of our lives that we care about, belonging, being accepted, being respected. I also think it typically comes down to
这与其他人怎么想有关，但完美主义也是如此，即如果它不完美，如果它不是完全像我们想要的那样、正如我们想象的那样，当我们知道自己留下了糟糕的印象时，我们将如何生存？本质上，所有这些心理机制的作用是，它们把一件本该相当正常且相当无害的事情（比如在其他人面前说话）创造并变成了这种高度、高度、几乎是充满压力的体验，这种高风险的体验，这种感觉与我们关心的所有其他部分以及我们生活中所有其他重要部分（归属感、被接受、被尊重）紧密相连的体验。我也认为这通常归根结底在于
how we store embarrassing memories. Some people will walk on stage and like you can say they do not care. They do not care what you think about them. They have this aura, this confidence, this like magnetism. And I think that's because the way that they store embarrassing memories is very different to ours. You know, for me, after a week or two, my emotional attachment to something embarrassing tends to lessen. And by about two months, I tend to kind of forget, I don't really care about it anymore unless someone else brings it up. For others, these memories, don't last longer than a day, and then there are people for whom they last a lifetime. Their mind might hold on to these moments for years, even decades, because of how individually
我们如何储存尴尬的记忆。有些人走上舞台时，你可以看出他们根本不在乎。他们不在乎你怎么看他们。他们有一种气场、一种自信、一种磁场。我想这是因为他们储存尴尬记忆的方式与我们非常不同。你知道的，对我来说，在一两周后，我对尴尬事情的情感依恋往往会减弱。大约到了两个月左右，我基本上就会忘得差不多了，除非别人提起，否则我真的不在乎了。对其他人来说，这些记忆持续的时间不超过一天，然后还有些人的记忆会持续一辈子。他们的脑海可能会抓住这些时刻数年甚至几十年，因为这些记忆对他们个人来说
important they feel, and that individual perception of our memories influences how they are stored, for how long they are stored, and how easy it is for us to access them. So if you are someone who stores embarrassing memories quite well and has it so that they're easily accessible, when you step into, you know, an opportunity to public speak when you're in that situation, you can very easily reflect on a time when it didn't go the way that you want. It may also be linked to how, you know, fixated we get on these negative moments. Some people can brush past these moments easier than others. That's just part of life. It's linked to rumination. It's linked to sometimes even depression.
感觉非常重要，而我们对记忆的这种个人感知影响了它们的储存方式、储存时长以及我们调取它们的难易程度。所以，如果你是一个能把尴尬记忆储存得很好且很容易调取的人，当你踏上公开演讲的机会、处于那种情境时，你可以非常轻易地回想起事情没有按你预期发展的那一刻。它可能还与我们对这些负面时刻的执着程度有关。有些人可以比其他人更容易地把这些时刻抛在脑后。这只是生活的一部分。这与反刍思维有关。有时甚至与抑郁和焦虑有关。
and anxiety. And so those prior events where you felt judged, awkward, cringe on stage, even if nobody said anything, even if everybody thought you did amazing, for you, that is an important kind of warning sign. That is an important thing that you remember and that influences your further experiences of public speaking, making it so that it's quite scary, it's quite anxiety-inducing. All of this is basically to say that if you fear public speaking, if it's your worst nightmare like some 75% of us. Firstly, you are not alone, which is always comforting. Secondly, this is something that your brain is doing to protect you. It's just getting confused because there is no dangerous life-ending threat that could ever be attached to a work presentation
因此，那些你觉得被评判、尴尬、在舞台上感到窘迫的过往事件，即使没有人说什么，即使每个人都觉得你表现得棒极了，对你来说，那也是一个重要的警示信号。那是你记住并会影响你未来公开演讲经历的重要事情，使得它变得相当可怕、相当容易引发焦虑。这一切基本上都在说明，如果你害怕公开演讲，如果它像我们大约75%的人一样是你的噩梦。首先，你并不孤单，这总是令人宽慰的。其次，这是你的大脑在保护你。它只是搞混了，因为根本没有任何可能与工作汇报或辩论课演讲挂钩的、足以致命的危险威胁。但第三，我认为重要的是要记住，我们考虑自己的行动、言语和表现的次数，远比其他人要多得多。我们对自己的审视，远比其他人对我们的审视要严苛得多。这正是我想要深入探讨的。你和我对自己的刻薄程度，会远超其他人对我们的刻薄程度。我们对自己说的话是如此恶毒，如果换作别人对我们说这些，我们绝不会再和那个人说话了。我们对自己的信念，远比其他人对我们的信念要少。
or a speech for your debating class. But thirdly, I think it's important to remember that we think about our actions and our words and our performances are way more than others do. We scrutinize ourselves way more than others scrutinize us. This is really what I want to hone in on. You and I are going to be a lot meaner to ourselves than others will ever be to us. We say things so nasty to ourselves that if someone else was to say them, we would never speak to that person again. We believe far less in ourselves than anyone else would. you know your boss your friend your co-worker believes in you probably more than you believe in
你知道你的老板、你的朋友、你的同事对你的信念，可能比你自己对自己的信念还要多。所以当你感到自己开始紧张、当你发现自己对自然的评判恐惧感到担忧时，想一想你预期的评判或尴尬程度是什么水平？你预计会遇到什么？把它除以一千，把它除以一百万，那才是我们可能经历或接受的更现实的水平。无论如何，对公开演讲的恐惧可能会表现为逃避，我们知道这种逃避最初感觉很安全，但实际上却让我们错过了很多事情，同时还会让焦虑变得更严重。
yourself so when you feel yourself getting nervous when you feel yourself you know being concerned about the natural fear of judgment think about what level of judgment or embarrassment you expect what do you expect to encounter divide it by a thousand divide it by a million and that is a more realistic level of what we are likely to experience or receive. Regardless, a fear of public speaking can manifest in avoidance, which we know initially feels safe, but actually causes us to miss out on a lot of things, whilst also making the anxiety worse.
而逃避之所以会产生这种效果，是因为它从未给我们提供机会去证明我们那些不理性的恐惧是错误的。所以我们有这样一种恐惧：你要上台了，你要在Zoom上做展示了，无论是什么。只要想象一下你害怕做的与公开演讲有关的事情。你的大脑会把这种恐惧变成一个怪物。它会加上所有这些额外的内容、所有这些永远不会发生的多余可能性。由于所有这些预期性的焦虑，你很可能会去逃避那种经历。但通过逃避那种经历，你的大脑，
And the reason that avoidance does this is because it never provides us with the opportunity to prove our irrational fears wrong. So we have this fear that you're going to get on stage, you're going to present on Zoom, whatever it is. Just picture the thing that you're afraid of doing as it relates to public speaking. Your brain is going to take that fear and make it into a monster. It's going to add on all these extra parts, all these extra possibilities that are never going to happen. And because of all that anticipatory anxiety, you are probably going to avoid that experience. But in avoiding that experience, your brain, overreting that experience, your brain,
过度反应于那种经历的大脑，只能把那些凭空捏造的妄想或不理性恐惧当作“如果发生了会怎样”的证据。因为你没有让自己暴露在真实的事情中，或者你已经有一段时间没这么做了，所以你没有任何证据可以说：“嘿，其实事情从来没有我想象的那么糟。其实并没有那么可怕。我能做到这一点。”这种逃避会产生更多的焦虑，进而产生更多的你懂的，这成了一个循环。这也意味着，你知道的，有时那些最让我们害怕的事情，
only has the delusional or rational fears that it's concocted as evidence for what would have happened. Because you haven't exposed yourself to the actual real thing, or you haven't done so in a while, you have no evidence to say, hey, actually, it's never as bad as I think it is. It's actually not terrible. I can do this. And that avoidance creates more anxiety, which creates more avoidance. You just see how this becomes a cycle. It also means that, you know, sometimes the things that scare us the most, are actually the most important things to do.
实际上才是最重要去做的事情。我的一个朋友是个企业家，她真的很挣扎于公开演讲和做展示。当我和她聊起这个话题时，她对我说：“我知道你以前真的很怕这个。现在你真的是个专业人士了，当我需要提出令人信服的论点、发表精彩展示并说服他人时，你就是我仰慕的人。”而她对我说的是：
One of my friends is an entrepreneur, and she really struggles with public speaking and presenting. And what she said to me, when I was asking her about this topic, I was like, I know that you used to be really afraid of this. Now you are genuinely the pro, the person that I look up to when it comes to providing and presenting compelling, compelling arguments and convincing people. And what she said to me was like,
“我只是意识到，不这样做的代价要比这样做的代价高得多。事情往好的方向发展的机会，远远多于往坏的方向发展的机会。”带着这种心态，我今天有什么建议可以带给你，让你也能获得与她一样的顿悟？即使你没有那种顿悟，也能让它变得更加容易忍受。我记得当我们年轻的时候，总有人告诉我们，比如想象观众光着身子，或者穿着内衣。
I just realized the cost of not doing it was so much higher than the cost of doing it. Like, there was so many more opportunities for it to go right than for it to go wrong. So with that mindset in mind, what are the tips that I have for you today to bring about that same epiphany that she had? And even if you don't have that epiphany to just make it more bearable. I remember when we were younger, we always used to be told to, like, imagine the audience naked or, like, in their underwear.
老实说，我觉得这太诡异、太让人毛骨悚然了，而且极其没有帮助。所以我给出的大第一条也是最大的建议是：想象那个你认为公开演讲最厉害的人，或者你最崇拜的人，然后去效仿他们。对我来说，这个人就是我的朋友。她简直太棒了。真的没有人能把视线从她身上移开。她那么镇定自若、自信满满。所以当我必须做主题演讲时，比如我最近在悉尼西南偏南（South by Southwest）大会上做的那次演讲，我就在脑海中想象她。我想象她会如何保持仪态，她会穿什么衣服，她的语调会是怎样的，她的语速会是怎样的。这是一个绝妙的技巧，因为我们为自己树立了一个不会感到害怕的榜样。我们为自己树立了一个不会失败、我们所崇拜的人的心理范例，
I find that so weird and creepy, not going to lie. incredibly unhelpful. So my first and biggest tip is to picture the person that you think is the best at public speaking or the person you admire the most and emulate them. For me, it's my friend. She's just magnificent. Like no one will look away. She's so poised and self-assured. And so when I have to do keynote's like I did a recent talk at South by Southwest in Sydney. I imagined her. I thought about how she would hold herself, how she would dress, what her tone would be, what her pace would be. This is a great technique because we give ourselves a mental example of someone who wouldn't be scared. We give ourselves a mental example of someone who couldn't fail, who we admire,
我们几乎可以把对他们的印象当成盔甲穿在身上。通过想象自己就是这个自信的个体，我们参与了一个心理过程。这被称为建模（modelling）。这是一个植根于社会学习理论的概念。而社会学习理论是由阿尔伯特·班杜拉（Albert Bandura）提出的。如果你学过心理学，你大概对他的名字很熟悉。基本上，他的观点是，我们所有的行为都是通过观察和
and we can almost wear our image of them as an armour. By imagining ourselves as this confident individual, we engage in a psychological process. It's called modelling. And it's a concept that's rooted in social learning theory. And social learning theory was developed by Albert Bondura. You probably are familiar with his name if you've studied psychology. Basically, what he said was that we learn all behaviours by observing an
模仿他人来学习的。因此，当我们从心理上走进我们崇拜的人的鞋子里并模仿他们的行为时，我们基本上在做的事情就是激活与自信和能力相关的神经回路。我们有效地欺骗了自己的大脑，让它相信我们自己也拥有那些特质。这个技巧还利用了我们所说的具身认知（embodied cognition）。当我们采用自信演讲者的身体姿势、语调、语速时，这会影响我们的内部状态。我们在生理上的做法会影响我们的内在感受。所以当你宣称“我很自信”并且带着自信、专业来保持身姿、进行展示时，它会让你觉得你已经拥有了这些东西。因此，通过体现这个角色，我们能够做到的是
imitating others. So when we mentally step into the shoes of someone we admire and we model their behavior, basically what we are doing is we are activating neural pathways associated with confidence and competence. And we are effectively tricking our brain into believing that we possess those qualities ourselves. This technique also taps into what we call embodied cognition. When we adopt the physical posture, tone, pace of a confident speaker, this can influence our internal state. What we do physically influences how we feel internally. And so when you say, I'm confident and you hold yourself with confidence and you present with confidence and with expertise, it makes you feel like you already possess those things. So by embodying this persona, what we are able to do is
暂时绕过我们的恐惧反应，让我们专注于演讲，专注于表达我们的观点，而不是去关注它将引发的焦虑。我不仅将这个技巧用于公开演讲，还用于许多真正令人恐惧的活动，当我需要独自去某些地方、需要坐飞机、需要结识新朋友时。我发现这简直是一个不可思议的策略，心里想着：“好吧，是的，我是我，但我也是这个更自信版本的我，或者我是我心目中的这个榜样。他们会怎么做？他们会是什么样子的？我该如何几乎是去假装，或者取他们最好的一面、从他们身上能学到的一切，并把它带到当前的情境中？”如果你看过电视剧《足球教练》（Ted Lasso），我向所有人推荐这部剧，它是我有史以来最喜欢的电视剧，毫无疑问，最棒的。
temporarily bypass our fear response and allow us to just focus on speaking, focus on making our point rather than on the anxiety that it's going to elicit. I use this technique not just for public speaking, but for a lot of really fearful activities when I need to go to things alone, when I need to fly, when I need to meet new people. I find that it's just an incredible strategy to be like, okay, yes I am me, but I am also this more confident version of me, or I am this role model that I have. What would they do? What would they look like? How can I pretend almost or take what's best from them, what I can learn from them and bring it to the situation? If you have ever seen the TV show Ted Lasso, which I recommend to everyone, it's my favorite TV show of all time, hands down, the best.
那部剧里有一个叫丽贝卡（Rebecca）的角色。在剧中，她有一种练习方法，就是在上台发言之前，先把自己弄得显得非常高大。她把双臂举过头顶。她在镜子前站得笔直、高大、凶猛而勇敢。然后慢慢地，她把所有这些能量收回。她带着刚才向自己展示的那种同样的能量，走进了房间。去试试吧。看看它管不管用。
There is a character in that TV show called Rebecca. And in that show, she has this practice, this method of making herself appear really big before she goes on stage to talk. She raises her arms above her head. She stands strong and tall and fierce and brave in front of a mirror. And then slowly she brings all of that back. And she walks out into a room with the same energy that she just saw displayed to herself. Just try it. See if it works.
我掌握公开演讲的第二个技巧是：不要追求完美，顺其自然就行。我认为当我们害怕公开演讲时，我们最大的倾向就是排练、排练、排练、排练，只是练习、练习、练习，做到逐字逐句地了解一切，以便做好准备。老实说，做好准备是减轻压力的好方法。但我们也可能做得过头了，而且我认为过于严格地准备也有值得商榷的地方。人们往往喜欢写出庞大的演讲稿。
My second tip for mastering public speaking is don't. aim for perfect, just let yourself find the flow. I think our biggest inclination when we're scared of public speaking is to rehearse, to rehearse, to rehearse, to rehearse, just practice, practice, practice, to know everything word for word to be prepared. Honestly, being prepared is a great way to be less stressed. But we can also take it too far and I think there is something to be said about preparing too strictly. People often like to write out huge scripts. like word for word of things they want to say, because when we have a script like that, it provides us with a sense of control, which is a natural anxiety reliever.
就像逐字逐句写下他们想说的话一样，因为当我们拥有这样一份演讲稿时，它会给我们提供一种掌控感，这是一种天然的焦虑缓解剂。但我发现这可能会让人非常不知所措，因为你会变得过度执着、过度专注于在正确的时间、以正确的顺序准确说出你想说的话，这留下了很大的空间让你觉得自已犯了错，即使观众根本不知道你犯了错。也许你的时间掌控得不对。漏掉了一句话或一个你想说的词，却无法顺畅过渡并继续下去，因为你把自己和演讲稿绑得太紧了，根本没有即兴发挥的空间。问题在于，观众不会注意到你漏掉的那句话，因为他们
But I find that this can be really overwhelming because you become hyperfixated and overly focused on saying exactly what you wanted to say at the right time, in the right order, and that leaves a lot of room to feel like you've made a mistake, even if the audience doesn't know that you have. Maybe your timing was wrong. missed a sentence or a word that you wanted to say and instead of being able to segue and move on, because you have tied yourself so closely to a script, there's no room to improvise. The thing is, is that the audience won't notice the sentence that you've missed because they
并不知道它本来应该在那里，但他们会注意到你事后变得惊慌失措和压力山大时的反应。所以这是我喜欢记住的一点。你可能确切地知道自己想说什么、打算说什么，但你的观众不知道。他们没看过你的演讲稿，也不知道你的计划，他们会全盘接受你给他们的内容，并认为这简直太精彩了、这本来就是预期的效果。所以你应该真正放手一点点，尽管这感觉起来与直觉相悖。我喜欢这样做的方法是，是的，我确实会对我想说什么、想怎么说以及我的关键点做一个详尽的计划。有时我会写出一份完整的演讲稿，但随后我不会把厚厚的一叠纸带上舞台，
didn't know it was going to be there, but they will notice your reaction after the fact as you get flustered and stressed. So here's the thing I like to remember. You might know exactly what you want to say and what you intend to say your audience doesn't. They haven't seen your script, they don't know your plan, they will take whatever you give them and they will think that it's brilliant and that was always what was intended. So you should really feel free to release the reins a little bit, as counterintuitive as that feels. How I like to do this is that, yes, I do make an extensive plan of what I want to say, how I want to say it, my key points. And sometimes I will write out a full script, but then instead of just bringing a big clump of pages onto stage, and then just staring down the whole time.
然后全程盯着看。我做的是创建四到五个部分，在每个部分中，我列出三个要点。这意味着在我的演讲、发言过程中，我有15个要点想要表达。而且每一个要点，它们的长度都不能超过10个词。我知道数字很多，但只要想象一下，为你的演讲准备五张卡片，五张卡片。每张卡片代表你想讲的一个新部分，
What I do is I create four to five sections, and within each of these sections, I make three main points. So it means that over the span of my talk, my speech, I have 15 main points that I want to make. And each of these points, they can't be any more than 10 words each. A lot of numbers I know, but just visualize having five cards, five cards for your speech. Each card is a new section of what you want to say,
每张卡片上只有三个要点。所以，举个例子，如果我要做一个关于，我不知道，比如大自然的心理益处以及我们如何将大自然融入我们的心理健康方法的演讲，我不会拿着一份演讲稿照本宣科地读一大段话，比如“自然野生动物研究所2012年的一篇文章提供了一个具体的估计，巴拉巴拉”，然后把这些原封不动地写下来照着纸念。
and each card only has three points on it. So, for example, if I'm doing a speech on, I don't know, like the psychological benefits of nature and how we could incorporate nature into our approach to mental health, instead of having a script in which I read off a huge paragraph like a 2012 article from the Natural Wildlife Institute provided a concrete estimate of blah, blah, blah, and have that written out exactly that I need to read off the page.
相反，我会写一个要点，上面写着：突出益处、压力更小、更活在当下、对抑郁有益。然后因为我知道，而且我已经练习过、在研究上花过时间，我知道我可以把这一点讲出来，而不必对着纸念。我在本集开头说过一句话，与这个技巧真正相关，那就是自我信任——相信当你走上那个舞台、走进那个房间、连上那个Zoom通话，无论是什么。实际上，你的大脑比你想象的要能干得多，你也比你想象的要更能干得多，
Instead, I will have a point that says highlight benefits, less stress, more present, good for depression. And then because I know, and I have practiced and I've spent time in my research, I know that I can bring that up rather than having to read it off the page. And I said something at the beginning of this episode that really relates to this tip, and that is self-trust, trusting that when you get up onto that stage, into that room, onto that Zoom call, whatever it is. You actually, your brain is a lot more capable than you think you are a lot more capable
能够记住你需要说的话。我也喜欢把我的手卡、标语牌或无论你叫它们什么的东西制作得具有非常鲜明的结构。我会使用荧光笔、红笔来勾勒出关键词，这样如果我迷失了方向、感到惊慌失措，我也有了一个锚，对吧？我有一个可以回归的东西。这样我就不会在这一切的即兴发挥中迷失自我。就像我不是完全在即兴乱说，但我也不会
than you think of remembering what you need to say. I also like to create my hand cards, placards, whatever you call them, such that they have a very distinct structure. And I use highlighter, red pen to just pull out keywords so that if I'm getting lost and flustered, I have this anchor, right? I have this thing that I can come back to. So I don't lose myself in like the spontaneity of it all. Like I'm not completely ad-libbing, but I'm also not.
因为被框死而感到压力山大。我认为这是任何事情的秘诀：当你追求完美时，你会达不到目标；但当你追求良好、自然和真实时，你会无限接近你想要的结果。所以，有时精通公开演讲实际上是在做与你的直觉相反的事情，稍微放松一点控制。我们今天分享的策略已经进行了一半左右。当我们回来时，我想讨论另外三个让我成为出色公开演讲者的重要技巧。我们马上回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、
not stressed out by being boxed in. I think this is the secret for anything that when you aim for perfect, you will fall short, but when you aim for good and natural and authentic, you get a lot closer to the outcome that you want. So sometimes getting good at public speaking is actually doing the opposite of your instincts, loosening the control a little bit. We are about halfway through my strategies today. So when we return, I want to talk about three more important tips that made me a great public speaker. We'll be back very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越主导健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates. the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
收听《2%》。即iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Percent。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill），大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅因为国会。快克可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊快克可卡因，只是想让你们大家知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of Congress. crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point,
这是我们讨论快克可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你接上那句话。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。
this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most
在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难抉择》，我是你们的主持人，
important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host,
也是你最喜欢的治疗师，凯尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。
and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations
我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个在世的好人很重要？
with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize
你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能发自内心地去做一个好人。和我凯尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难抉择》中，就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标进行真实的对话。
that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。
on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.
这是《情感陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情感陷阱》播客。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
破案需要动用一大群网络侦探。我希望人们能看到他们的税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取节目的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客
podcasts. Anxiety has like this image in my mind and in many of our minds of being this like very fast emotion, this like speedy, erratic, run around the house, jittery buzzed emotion. Because that is essentially what it does to our nervous system. It pumps a whole lot of energy into us to prepare to fight or run away from a danger. danger, when that energy has nowhere to go, it finds a way out through this jitteriness, through this intensity and this speed. How that will show up when we're public speaking and this is an entirely natural response is that we do tend to at the beginning feel very hot and flushed and rushed.
播客。焦虑在我的脑海和我们许多人的脑海中，就像是一种非常快速的情绪，一种风风火火、反复无常、在屋里跑来跑去、神经质且让人嗡嗡作响的情绪。因为这基本上就是它对我们的神经系统所做的事情。它向我们体内注入大量能量，让我们准备好战斗或逃离危险。当这些能量无处可去时，它就会通过这种神经质、通过这种强度和速度找到宣泄的出口。当我们在公开演讲时表现出这一点时——这是一种完全自然的反应——我们往往会在开始时感到非常灼热、脸红和匆忙。
We stumble, we feel jittery, we feel anxious, we can't really focus on where we want to look. Totally normal. When you find yourself, in that space, pause, slow it down, take your breath. This helps calm your nerves. It helps communicate to yourself and your mind that there is no danger. If there was danger, why would you be slowing down? When we slow down and take deliberate pauses, we not only regain control over our breathing and our heart rate as well, but we also engage what we call the parasympathetic nervous system. The parasympathetic nervous system counteracts our flight or fight response. So essentially what it does is it goes, okay, hold up, false alarm.
我们会结巴，会感到紧张，会感到焦虑，无法真正集中精力去看我们想看的地方。这完全正常。当你发现自己处于那种状态时，停下来，慢下来，做个深呼吸。这有助于平静你的神经。它有助于向你自己和你的大脑传达没有危险的信息。如果有危险，你为什么要慢下来？当我们慢下来并进行深思熟虑的停顿平衡时，我们不仅重新控制了我们的呼吸和心率，而且我们还激活了我们所谓的副交感神经系统。副交感神经系统会抵消我们的战斗或逃跑反应。所以它本质上所做的就是，它会说，好吧，等等，虚惊一场。
Let's just take a breath, slow it down. Let's ground ourselves in the present moment and it reduces the intensity of anxiety's physical symptoms. It also has the added bonus of making what you're saying feel more impactful and important. You know, when I talk like this and I'm like rushing and I'm just like, I want to make my point, you're not listening as much as when I'm really focusing in on what I want to say and slowing down between my words. It gives the audience time to absorb and reflect on what you're saying. It enhances their engagement. It creates a rhythm that commands attention. It signals confidence and poise because you know that what you have to say is important. You don't need to rush through it.
让我们做个深呼吸，慢下来。让我们立足于当下，它会减轻焦虑带来的身体症状的强度。它还有一个额外的好处，就是让你所说的话感觉更有影响力和更重要。你知道，当我像这样说话，而且我很匆忙，我只是想表达我的观点时，你们听的没有当我真正专注于我想说的话并在字里行间慢下来时那么多。它给观众时间去吸收和反思你所说的话。它增强了他们的参与度。它创造了一种能吸引注意力的节奏。它标志着自信和沉着，因为你知道你要说的话很重要。你不需要匆忙讲完。
And over time, practicing this like intentional pacing and slowing down, it trains our brain to associate public speaking with calmness rather than fear. And so it rewires our response to these situations. I really learnt this through trial and error. I remember having to do this presentation when I was maybe 22. And it was actually really important. It was back, I think I had just finished uni. I can't actually remember the social. circumstances of it. It was a work presentation, like maybe an employee presentation. And I remember it was
随着时间的推移，练习这种有意识的节奏控制和放慢速度，会训练我们的大脑将公开演讲与平静联系起来，而不是恐惧。因此，它重新连接了我们对这些情况的反应。我真的是通过不断试错才学会这一点的。我记得在我大概22岁的时候，不得不做这样一个演讲。其实这真的很重要。那是以前，我想我刚大学毕业。我其实记不清当时的具体社交情况了。这是一场工作演示，可能是一场员工演示。我记得那是
in front of maybe 15 people. Ah, it was like a interview to be promoted. And I was, you had to give a talk. Sorry, details, not necessary, but you had to give a talk, to present on something in front of like a panel of 15 people, room of 15 people. And I just got so frazzled that I just kept talking. And then suddenly I was saying things that I didn't mean. Suddenly I was going way too fast. I couldn't stop myself. It all just like tumbled away from me. And afterwards I was really embarrassed.
在大约15个人面前。啊，这就像是一场晋升面试。然后你必须做一个演讲。抱歉，细节不重要，但你必须做一个演讲，在一个由15个人组成的评审团、一个有15个人的房间里展示一些东西。我当时太慌乱了，以至于我一直在说话。然后突然间我说了一些我并不想说的话。突然间我的语速太快了。我无法控制自己。这一切就像从我身边崩塌了一样。事后我真的很尴尬。
I was like, that was not what I wanted to do. That wasn't the energy that I wanted to bring into this situation. And I really was like, okay, what could have I, what should I have done differently? And the one thing that kept coming to my mind was like, you should have just paused. You should have just taken a really deep breath and been silent. Because silence is actually quite powerful. Here are some other ways that we can really positively manage our anxiety in these situations. Treat your anxiety like excitement.
我想，这根本不是我想做的。这不是我想带进这种状态的能量。我真的在想，好吧，我本可以、我本应该做出什么不同的改变？不断浮现在我脑海中的一件事就是：你本该停下来。你本该深深地吸一口气，然后保持沉默。因为沉默其实很有力量。以下是我们在这些情况下积极管理焦虑的其他一些方法。把你的焦虑当作兴奋。
I've spoken about this before. It doesn't work for everything. In this situation, it is a game changer. We know that anxiety and excitement, they activate very similar like pathways through the brain, very similar areas in our body. So excitement, the nervousness, the ball of energy in your stomach, the eyes darting across the room, that like energy you can feel rising to the top of your head. That shares a lot of similarities and parallels with what it feels like for your anxiety to be increasing.
我以前说过这个。它并不适用于所有情况。但在这种情况下，这是一个颠覆局面的关键。我们知道焦虑和兴奋，它们通过大脑激活非常相似的途径，激活我们身体中非常相似的区域。所以兴奋、紧张、胃里的能量团、在房间里游移的眼睛、那种你能感觉到直冲头顶的能量。这与你的焦虑不断增加时的感觉有很多相似之处和平行之处。
So taking a more cognitive mental approach, you can basically say to yourself, wow, I'm so excited by this feeling. I'm so excited by this opportunity to deliver this speech. Not I'm excited for it to be over, but I'm excited to test myself. If this goes wrong, that's okay. I'm excited by the possibility to learn. The anxiety is still there, but the label is different, and labeling your emotions is invaluable.
因此，采取更具认知性的心理方法，你基本上可以对自己说：“哇，我对这种感觉感到非常兴奋。我对这次发表演讲的机会感到非常兴奋。”不是“我很高兴它快结束了”，而是“我很高兴能考验一下自己。如果这搞砸了，没关系。我很高兴能有学习的可能性。”焦虑依然存在，但标签不同了，给你的情绪贴上标签是无价的。
How you interpret and perceive your emotions has been shown to influence how you experience them. I also would say if it's an environment where you are on a stage or in an open space, move around, pace around, give that energy that's sitting in your body somewhere to go, pacing and like purposeful movement during your speech, not only does it release some of the anxiety from your body, it also really enhances your confidence and the audience's engagement. Psychologically, we know that movement helps calm and channel nervous energy
你如何解释和感知你的情绪已被证明会影响你体验它们的方式。我还想说，如果这是一个你在舞台上或开阔空间的环境，四处走动，踱步，给坐在你身体里的能量一个去处，在演讲期间踱步和进行有目的的移动，不仅会释放你身体里的一些焦虑，还会真正增强你的自信心和观众的参与度。从心理学上讲，我们知道运动有助于平静和引导紧张能量
by really providing like a physical outlet for our body's natural fight or flight response. For the audience though, movement creates visual interest. It keeps their attention focused. As humans, we are naturally drawn to motion. You know, we're intrigued.
通过为我们身体自然的战斗或逃跑反应提供一个真正的物理出口。不过，对于观众来说，运动会产生视觉兴趣。它能集中他们的注意力。作为人类，我们天生就被运动所吸引。你知道，我们很好奇。
Like, what does that signal? So pacing is really important in that regard as well. Has the dual benefit of making you feel better and making the audience feel more engaged? It can also serve as a really important nonverbal cue. So, you know, when you're moving into a new part of your speech, you know, as you walk, it emphasizes a transition. And it can also improve memory. I read this really interesting study that really good public speakers, I guess it wasn't really a study, it was like an article.
这说明了什么？所以在这方面踱步也非常重要。具有让你感觉更好、让观众感觉更投入的双重好处。它还可以作为一个非常重要的非语言线索。所以，你知道，当你进入演讲的新部分时，当你走动时，它强调了一个过渡。它还可以改善记忆力。我读过一项非常有趣的研究，优秀的公众演讲者，我想这其实不是一项研究，而是一篇类似文章的东西。
Really good public speakers use certain movements to bring about flow to make it feel like what they're talking about, has more of a fluidity to it and to remember key parts of what they want to say. So, you know, they associate standing in the left corner of a stage with the first point they want to make, standing in the right corner with the second point they want to make. A little bit advanced, but it really does show the alignment of the physical and the mental and the emotional when it comes to mastering public speaking. With that, I would also say, you know, audience engagement is key. Pacing is one way to do it. Sowing down and speeding up your pacing for your voice and your tone is really great. Also, my mum taught me this. Focus on a new person every 20 seconds. What says anxiety
优秀的公众演讲者会使用某些动作来带来流畅感，让他们所谈论的内容感觉更有流动性，并记住他们想要表达的关键部分。所以，你知道，他们会将站在舞台左角与他们想提出的第一个观点联系起来，将站在右角与他们想提出的第二个观点联系起来。这有点高级，但它确实显示了在掌握公开演讲时身体、心理和情感的一致性。在此，我也想说，观众的参与是关键。节奏是方法之一。放慢或加快声音和语调的节奏真的很棒。另外，我妈妈教过我这个。每20秒关注一个新的人。还有什么比游移的眼神更能说明焦虑呢？
more than darting eyes? It's a natural feeling though. You know, darting eyes is basically our brain being like scan. You know, this is a scary situation. I want to scan my environment for threats. Slowly, intentionally focus on one person every 20 seconds. It can feel rather intense, but it kind of also brings about an accountability of like, oh my God, they're watching me, I better pay attention. And so again, it means that people really feel that you have something to say. If you are saying it to them, also making eye contact engages the audience's mirror neurons, which really helps create a sense of connection and empathy. And it gives you an anchor.
但这是一种自然的感受。你知道，游移的眼神基本上就是我们的大脑在说“扫描”。你知道，这是一个可怕的情况。我想在我的环境中扫描威胁。缓慢地、有意识地每20秒关注一个人。这可能会感觉相当强烈，但它也在某种程度上带来了一种责任感，比如“哦天哪，他们在看着我，我最好专心点”。因此，再次说明，这意味着人们真的觉得你有话要说。如果你是对他们说的，眼神交流也会激活观众的镜像神经元，这确实有助于建立一种联系感和同理心。它为你提供了一个锚点。
I talked about the anchor in the form of specific words that you highlight. A person in the crowd can also be an anchor, a really, really valuable one. Finally, I just want to give you a little bit of a pep talk. If you are listening to this in preparation for a big speech or you're trying to get ready and get your skills sharpened, you're going to do amazing. The fact that you care enough to be listening to something like this, wanting to really hone in on your skill set,
我刚才谈到了以你强调的具体词汇形式存在的锚点。人群中的某个人也可以是一个锚点，一个非常非常有价值的锚点。最后，我只是想给你一小段鼓舞士气的话。如果你正在听这个来为一场大型演讲做准备，或者你正试图准备好并磨练你的技能，你一定会做得很棒。你足够关心去听这样的东西，想要真正磨练你的技能集，
and what is such an important skill to have, shows that you have an attitude of confidence in your ability. It shows that you have an attitude that is centered on wanting to do well, that is centered on wanting to do your best, that is going to come through. That excitement for this experience, even if it feels like anxiety right now, is going to come through. remember that you are much more capable than you ever think you are upon first assessment.
在拥有如此重要的技能时，这表明你对自己的能力抱有自信的态度。这表明你的态度是以想要做好为核心的，以想要做到最好为核心的，这将会显现出来。对这段经历的兴奋，即使现在感觉像是焦虑，也会显现出来。记住，你比你初次评估时想象的要更有能力得多。
You are so capable. You've done so many hard things. You've also probably done a speech before, or debated or done some public speaking. And you get that buzz afterwards. You get that high. It always works out as much better than you think it will. And even when it doesn't, you're still here. You survived.
你非常有能力。你做过那么多艰难的事情。你以前可能也做过演讲，或者进行过辩论或做过一些公开演讲。事后你会得到那种快感。你会得到那种兴奋感。结果总是比你想象的要好得多。即使有时不如意，你依然在这里。你挺过来了。
You're still okay. And there are people who care about you that weren't in that room or who weren't still care about you. your whole life is not touched by one speech or one presentation. I also think of people like Jennifer Lawrence who literally fell on her face when she got her first Oscar. And, you know, it became not something that she was judged by. It became a funny little gag. Like no one really thought anything too deep about that. We scrutinize our behavior so much more than others do.
你还是好好的。而且还有那些关心你的人，他们不在那个房间里，或者不在乎你。你的整个人生不会被一次演讲或一次展示所左右。我也想到像詹妮弗·劳伦斯这样的人，她在获得第一座奥斯卡奖时真的脸朝下摔倒了。而且，你知道，这并没有成为人们评判她的事。它成了一个有趣的笑话。就像没有人真正对那件事进行过深思熟虑一样。我们对自己的行为的审视比别人要多得多。
So I really want you to hold strong to that knowledge. and I'm sure you're going to do absolutely amazing. I hope that these tips and the psychology behind them and why they do work and how they've worked for me also really supports you and whatever you have coming up. If there is someone else you know who needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share it with them. It really helps the show to grow, which we value so deeply.
所以我真的希望你坚守这个信念，我相信你一定会做得很棒。我希望这些技巧以及背后的心理学、它们为什么起作用以及它们如何对我起作用，也能真正支持你和你即将面临的任何事情。如果你认识其他人也需要听这期节目，请随时与他们分享。这真的对节目的成长很有帮助，我们对此深表感激。
I'm also really trying to get people to leave reviews for the podcast. It's something that actually is insanely helpful not just for like reaching new people but also just for growing our own community and they also selfishly make my day make sure that you are following us on instagram it is at that psychology podcast if you have episode suggestions if you have any more tips that you think people could benefit from when it comes to public speaking please feel free to share them with me and i'll share them on until next time stay safe be kind be gentle to yourself and we will talk very very certain. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist
我也真的很想让人们为播客留下评价。这件事实际上极其有用，不仅是为了触达新群体，也是为了发展我们自己的社区，而且自私地说，它们会让我的一天都变得美好。请确保你在Instagram上关注我们，账号是that psychology podcast。如果你有节目建议，或者你有更多你认为人们在公开演讲时能受益的技巧，请随时与我分享，我会在节目中分享。下次见之前，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加梅斯主持的《知难而退》。
and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方真正谈论都不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《知难而退》。在2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped.
你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑子炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和构建弹性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other. side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
让自己经历一些苦难，你最终会熬过去。成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》，即TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girl. Friends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜们，相信我，宝贝》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。